And the keeper of the prison
committed to Joseph's hand.
All the prisoners that were
in the prison whatsoever,
they did there he was the doer of it.
The keeper of the prison look not to
anything that was under his hand because
the Lord was with him.
And that what she did,
the Lord made it to prosper.
So it's a repeat.
It's a repeat of exactly what happened
when he was the slave of the pharaoh,
except it's one rung deeper into hell,
so to speak.
Right?
So it's slave pharaoh and here
it's prisoner jail master,
but it doesn't matter.
The same thing happens.
So now Joseph has imprisoned and the
Pharaoh has a fit one day of peak and
throws the chief of his Butler's into
prison and the chief of his bakers and
they have a dream,
each of them.
And,
uh,
Joseph interprets the dreams,
just seems to be something that he can do.
And uh,
he tells the Butler that history means
that the f Pharaoh was going to forgive
him and put him back in his position
and he tells the baker that the Pharaoh
isn't going to forgive him.
And that he's going to take off
his head and hang them in a tree,
which rather rough dream.
But that is what happens.
That's what happens.
So anyways,
that the baker or the Butler
goes free and Joseph says,
look,
you know,
maybe you could just keep
in mind the fact that I
did you a bit of a favor here and told
you something that was accurate but that
the chief didn't really remember once he,
once he was freed
interpreting dreams in prison.
And so now the pharaoh has a dream
and he actually has two dreams.
So it's another one of
those doubled motifs.
So the idea is these are really important
dreams because they came in a pair and
behold there came out of the river
seven well favored kind and fat fleshed,
so cattle and they fed the meadow,
meadow and behold seven other
cattle came up after the motive.
The river ill favored and lean fleshed,
starving and stood by the other cows
on the brink of the river and the ill
favored and lean fleshed kind did eat
up the seven well favored and fat.
So feral,
it woke pay,
fair enough.
It's pretty nasty dream.
And then he has another dream big go to
hit it home and he slept and dreamt the
second time.
And behold seven years of corn came up
upon one stock rank and good and behold
seven thin years and blasted with the
east wind sprung up after them and the
seven thin years devoured the
seven rank and full years.
And Pharaoh woke and beheld it was a
dream and then it says a little later.
And for that the dream was
doubled unto Pharaoh twice.
It is because the thing is established
by God and God will shortly bring it to
pass.
It's interesting,
you know,
because one of the better theories about
dreams is that they're part of the way
that the right and left hemisphere
communicate or maybe the nonverbal of the
brain communicates with the verbal brain,
verbal part of the brain.
And so the nonverbal part of the brain
which is less differentiated and thinks
more globally,
is looking for patterns
and anomalies in the world.
Things that don't fit well with the
current way of conceptualizing the world.
Things that make you anxious and
uncertain and those are things you haven't
mastered,
right?
So they don't fit well into your
conception of realization of the world by
definition.
Because if you had mastered them,
they wouldn't make you anxious,
nervous.
And so the the nonverbal parts of
your brain or like an alarm system,
they're looking around for places where
you're probably wrong and then they put
those in images and try to conceptualize
them so that you can update your model
of reality to take them into account.
But that also produces a
fair bit of negative emotion,
especially at night.
And so,
so we know that we know if you deprive
people of dreams that they go insane very
rapidly.
Animals as well,
necessary part of mental equilibrium.
The way you do that with rats in Casey
want to know is that you've got rats that
you want to drive insane.
This is how you do it.
So you put the rat on a like a pedestal.
It's pretty small.
And then when he fought,
that's surrounded by water
and then when he falls asleep,
his nose hits the water,
then he wakes up.
And so you can deprive the route of sleep.
And that doesn't,
the rats don't respond to that very
well after some period of time.
So that's one of the ways
that that's been discovered.
But anyways,
the dream does seem to
be an update mechanism.
And so if,
if,
if you have a very powerful dream,
like a nightmare,
especially if it's repeating,
it's like something is trying to hammer
on the door that needs to be let in,
and often you don't know
how to let it in and that's,
that's a problem.